[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
50 años después de la última misión
parece que el ser humano tiene fijada de
nuevo su vista sobre la luna la puesta
en marcha del programa artemis ha traído
un proyecto que pretende devolver al ser
humano a nuestro satélite y desarrollar
una estación espacial permanente que
pueda servir en un futuro viaje a marte
pasos importantes que continúan la
carrera espacial que la humanidad vivió
durante el siglo pasado y que en france
24 repasamos la carrera por llegar al
espacio exterior y a la luna comenzó a
tomar forma en plena guerra fría entre
la unión soviética y eeuu
estas dos superpotencias vieron que
estas misiones podrían mostrar la
superioridad sobre el rival en esta
carrera la urss comenzó con ventaja al
enviar a la perrita laika al espacio en
1957 el primer ser vivo en conseguirlo y
al hacer en 1961 que yuri gagarín se
convirtiera en el primer hombre en salir
del planeta tierra un acontecimiento que
que eeuu se fijara el objetivo de llegar
a la luna lo antes posible para marcar
ese hito
creo que esta nación debe comprometerse
a lograr la meta antes de que se acabe
esta década de llevar un hombre a la
luna y devolverlo sano y salvo la tierra
es a partir de estas palabras del ex
presidente kennedy cuando en 1967 se
puso en marcha el programa apolo una
labor que supondría una enorme inversión
económica
tecnológica y de personal que solamente
se puede entender en un contexto de
máxima tensión con la unión soviética
las primeras misiones fueron de
monitoreo y prueba hasta que se puso en
marcha la misión apolo 11 una
tripulación formada por neil armstrong
buzz aldrin y michael collins salió con
el objetivo de alunizar sobre el
satélite el hito se alcanzó el 20 de
julio de 1969 cuando neil armstrong y
buzz aldrin se convirtieron en los
primeros seres humanos en pisar la luna
el evento fue un fuerte golpe
propagandístico de eeuu ya que millones
de personas
desde sus hogares para la historia
quedarán las palabras pronunciadas por
armstrong al salir de la cápsula
espacial
es un pequeño paso para el hombre
pero un gran salto para la humanidad
pero más allá del apolo 11 las misiones
tripuladas a la luna siguieron
realizándose por parte de eeuu durante
los siguientes años entre 1969 y 1972
eeuu ejecutó otros seis lanzamientos
tripulados a la luna de los que cinco
tuvieron éxito y solamente uno tuvo que
suspenderse por fallas técnicas las
siguientes misiones pudieron explorar
más el terreno del satélite recoger
decenas de kilos de material para
muestras e incluso recorrer la
superficie con un vehículo pero tras
seis misiones exitosas y el alunizaje de
12 personas la misión del apolo 17 en
diciembre de 1972 se convirtió en la
última por más de 50 años nadie ha
vuelto a pisar la luna a pesar de que
las misiones no tripuladas si han
continuado algo que incluso ha levantado
teorías conspiratorias con respecto a la
autenticidad de los viajes lunares que
se vieron a finales de la década de 1960
y principios de 1970
pero más allá de la rumorología lo que
sucedió es que una vez logrado el hito
se perdió el interés por un programa tan
costoso que en realidad no aportaba un
beneficio claro más allá del
propagandístico en 1991 la unión
soviética se disolvió y la guerra fría
finalizó por lo que las inversiones en
programas espaciales de la nasa bajaron
drásticamente y además esta organización
se centró en otros proyectos como la
construcción de una estación espacial
internacional junto con rusia no
obstante esta situación parece haber
cambiado en los últimos años otras
naciones como china han comenzado sus
carreras espaciales y la aparición de
empresas privadas como spacex o blue
origin han reactivado el deseo de volver
a la luna en este contexto es en el que
se ideó artemis desde principios del
siglo 21 se empezó a plantear la
posibilidad de volver a tener viajes
tripulados a la luna y tras una serie de
retrasos y cancelaciones todo parece
indicar que eso será posible en 2025
artemis tendrá dos misiones de prueba en
2022 y 2 24 y en su tercer viaje varias
personas entre ellas una mujer y una
persona afro podrán pisar la luna además
pretende llegar a la luna con cohetes de
98 metros de longitud un tamaño más
grande de lo habitual
estas son las tres misiones confirmadas
pero durante los siguientes años se
tiene previsto realizar más misiones por
diferentes objetivos además de aumentar
la recogida de muestras y análisis sobre
los materiales que componen nuestro
satélite
la nasa pretende establecer con la ayuda
de la compañía spacex una estación
espacial permanente en la órbita lunar
que pueda servir en el futuro como
parada de repostaje y almacenamiento
para futuros viajes que lleven a
destinos más lejanos
especialmente cuando se tiene en mente
poder llegar a marte con una nave
tripulada a lo largo de este siglo no es
first men esta primera misión es la
primera prueba de los sistemas de
transporte en el espacio profundo antes
de ponerles tripulación pero eso también
nos prepara para estar a largo plazo en
la luna y para nuestra enorme campaña
hacia marte mars
no es el único proyecto existente en
esta carrera ya no hay solamente dos
potencias que compiten entre sí otras
naciones como china ya tienen previsto
crear sus propias estaciones espaciales
y países como emiratos árabes unidos
arabia saudita o india ya tienen planes
para llegar al espacio e incluso con el
tiempo a la luna algo que muy
probablemente elevará la competencia con
esto concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]